(air whooshing)
(clock ticking)
- I would argue that I'm
still not great at it,
and I was borderline atrocious at it
the first 15 to 16 years of my career.
(high-pitched music)
(men exclaiming)
You got your perspective.
(upbeat music)
(crowd roaring)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(camera snapping)
(funky keyboard music)
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
I was, I've already decided,
I don't think my team even knows this,
that I'm changing the
name of "Interrupted By,"
yeah, because, just like
reading the comments,
I just don't, I think it triples-down on
something I don't want it to,
so the reality is that
show's now canceled.
And so now I just interview friends,
people I'm interested in,
and I have a really dear friend here
who I haven't seen in a little while.
So it's nice to see you.
Who, we're gonna talk about music and tech
and things of that nature.
Like I've said, some of the people I know
occasionally reach out and they're like,
"Hey, I wanna yap and talk about stuff."
And I'm like yeah, let's do it.
So, no prep, I literally just walked in
and here we are.
So, why don't you tell the Vayner Nation,
all the people listening,
who you are, what you do,
and then we'll get into it.
- Sure.
I'm Milana, I'm the
founder and CEO of a music,
can you hear me, is this better?
- Yeah, probably better.
- Sorry.
(muffled speaking)
Oh, got it, okay.
I'm so new to this whole podcast thing.
So you're gonna have
to teach me the ropes.
- Have you ever done a podcast, Milana?
- I've done a couple.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
- But this is a new mic
setup, I haven't seen that.
- Yeah, it's, we're
very crazy around here.
- No, you guys are very like,
you got it all together,
it's all set up, I love it.
So, again, I'm Milana,
I'm the co-founder and CEO
of a company called Stem.
And our mission is to help artists
build sustainable businesses.
And when we talk about artists,
it's primarily musicians today.
And the platform allows a
lot of independent artists
to get their music on Apple and Spotify,
all the major platforms.
And the thing that we
do that no one else does
is we automate the splits
on all of the payouts
to all the collaborators.
So if you see a collaboration
with a bunch of rappers,
and it's out independently,
chances are it's through Stem.
- Understood.
So, up for full disclosure,
I'm an investor in this company,
we've known each other a long time.
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Phil is in the building,
which is always nice,
good to see you, Phil.
- [Phil] Nice to see you.
- Back there, who's been staying
close to this investment.
And so how's it been going?
And when you talk about distributions,
the thing that most drew
me to the opportunity,
what is it, like, four years ago now?
- It'll be four years ago
since I told you about it,
five years ago since
we started the company.
- [Gary] Jesus, so--
- Or, no, that's a lie,
five years since I told you
about it, four years since
we started it.
- [Gary] Started it,
makes sense.
So, one of the things I really liked was,
the YouTube ecosystem was
super-confusing at the time.
- [Milana] Yep.
- It still may be.
That's really my question.
Has, you know it's one
thing, to your point,
when three people, two
signed, one unsigned,
collab on a song and
it's super-complicated,
I've learned that lesson.
I had a song that I made
for Clouds and Dirt,
my sneaker, with Gunna,
Tierra Whack, and Tee Grizzly
that was 38 seconds from
being uploaded to Spotify,
launching with my sneaker,
that died because it just died.
How's that been working
and how has the YouTube
Ecosystem worked out
and what has emerged, whether it's TikTok
or other things of that nature?
- Yeah, definitely, so
YouTube is still, I believe,
the largest music platform,
for streaming, right?
And I think a big part of it
is because it's totally global.
Spotify didn't launch globally.
Initially, at least,
and now it's continuing to grow that way.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But when we started,
the other problem I wanted to solve
was that there were all these
content creators on YouTube
that were collaborating, right?
And when they would want to post a video,
and it was two different channels,
they would post the same video twice
and bifurcate the views.
And the reason they would do that
is because they wanted
to each monetize it.
And so we thought to ourselves,
"Well, why don't we just
split the revenue from it?"
Right?
When you have apps like
Venmo and all these others
that make it so easy to
send money on the internet.
If you're making money on the internet,
why can't you just share it?
- So what happens now?
Like if me and Phil both have channels,
like does one pick to air it on theirs
and just kicks it to the other person?
- Yeah, I mean they would
Venmo each other the money,
unless you go through Stem,
you register the video,
well, you can post it on both channels,
it can live on hundreds of channels.
We recognize when the
video's being consumed,
we collect the revenue
from YouTube directly,
and then each of you guys
have your own account
and you get paid every month.
- So, what's the biggest
learning you've had
in the past four years of going from
being an executive in companies and,
actually, give a little context.
What was your career
prior to co-founding Stem?
- Yeah, so I was one of the first
digital media talent agents in Hollywood.
I was brought on as an
agent at the age of 21,
which is ridiculous that
they would even hire me.
(laughs)
But my job was discovering
talent on the internet
and helping them break their concepts
into traditional media so,
Issa Rae I signed when she
had "Awkward Black Girl"
the channel on YouTube, got her book deal,
and then we packaged the TV show
and sold it to HBO, which
is now called "Insecure."
So it was being a part
of a lot of the talent
that was coming off the internet--
- Who was the first person you signed,
do you remember?
- That's a great question.
- Was it Toronto Tar-tar?
(laughing)
Phil?
- I wish.
I don't know, but I've
had really fun clients,
people like Josh Strovsky
who you guys know
as the Fat Jew.
I actually think one of
the first things I signed--
- Did you sign him first
or was he already signed
and then you kinda got him?
- (laughing) No, we signed him because
we signed a Twitter feed
called "White Girl Problems."
- Oh, I remember.
- That was one of the
early clients, I think.
- And he was behind that?
- He was close with the
writers of that, yeah.
- [Gary] Got it.
- And so we got connected
to him, all through that
kind of stuff.
- [Gary] Through that crew.
- Yep.
- That was their crew.
- It was fun, but that's
the thing that I noticed
is that more and more independent creators
were making real money online
and building real businesses.
And to me, it started to
really dispel this notion
of a starving artist, right?
Like, you and I have similar roots,
we're both from Babruysk
area and our families,
Russian immigrants to the states.
And when I told my parents in high school
that I wanted to go to film
school and be a producer,
they're like, "That's a great
hobby, but not a career."
- [Gary] Right.
- And that crushed me.
And so what I wanted to
do was to help artists
be able to not only build careers,
but businesses off of doing
what they're great at.
And I felt like the thing that
was really preventing them
was just tools, and more importantly,
visibility into their finances.
So the thing that I've learned
is that it's amazing how
how easy it is for a person to understand
their business when
they see their numbers.
And numbers with a dollar
sign in front of them.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And like artists have
always been told, "Hey--
- "I've got this covered."
- "I've got this covered,
"let someone else focus on the business."
- "You worry about being
creative and enjoy."
- Totally, and I think that's bullshit.
- Yep.
What was the biggest surprise to you
versus the ideology of what you
thought entrepreneurship was
four years ago--
- [Milana] Yeah.
- To now it's true realities
now that you live in it?
- I think it's all about the
people around you, right?
How do you really
align people with your vision?
And it takes so much repetition
to get people I think to truly understand
what they're rowing towards as a team.
And I think that you, at least
when I would read about it
in books or hear other
people talking about it,
it sounded like "Oh,
it can't be that hard."
But it's actually, I think,
the fundamental thing
that you have to get right.
- Yeah, I understand.
I mean it's really funny,
I had an employee that's worked
at Vayner for seven years
come into my office last
year, late last year,
and say, "Hey, like," super-frustrated,
and the person was like,
"What are we even doing here?"
And I started laughing
because we had a great, warm relationship
and I didn't feel like
it was disrespectful.
And I'm like, "I have only
repeated 700,000 times
to your face that we're
building a platform to buy
brands when the economy
collapses" to like,
it was like super-laughable.
- [Milana] Right.
- But I think it's a
really good demonstration
of what you're talking about.
Because
people,
when they're employees,
and you've been one so you know this,
inherently subconsciously have to have
some level of fear base in them,
that the company may be
not telling you the truth.
It's just the inherent human nature of
the employer/employee relationship and so
reaffirming the mission or what
you're trying to accomplish,
even if it's super-simplistic,
- [Milana] Oh yeah.
- Is oftentimes not
not consumed because
one has to worry about
themselves as an employee.
And is always worried that
the other shoe might drop.
- I mean, it's crazy, even
when you're trying to be
as clear as possible, right?
Clarity is one of our values
because we're dealing in a business
that's considered really
intentionally opaque
and we're trying to change all that.
But like we out of every
all hands show the business,
the company metrics--
- How many employees are there now?
- We're about 35.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- It's a fun time.
- What about firing somebody?
- That's fucking hard.
- Yeah.
Was that hard for you?
- It was initially because I
didn't know how to do it well.
- [Gary] Right.
- But I feel like if you're
good at managing expectations
and setting really clear goals,
then by the time you have
to have that conversation
with someone that's about
them parting ways with you,
like they should already know,
it shouldn't be a surprise
and it shouldn't be a hard conversation.
- Yeah, I would argue that
I'm still not great at it
and I was borderline atrocious at it
the first 15 to 16 years of my career.
I just hated it.
- How'd you get better?
- (sighing deeply) AJ helped,
when AJ came to Vayner,
when I started with AJ,
he was much better at
it than me with candor,
which I think is the main part
to what you were talking about.
Just wanting to be better.
- [Milana] Yeah.
- You know, just realizing this was
one of the flaws in my system
that I would shock people.
It's nice to make it lovely and bubbly
and awesome 24/7, 365.
But if the movie ends with you firing them
and they're flabbergasted
'cause you've given them
no negative feedback, that's not good.
And I just had to get to
that place where I was like,
just had to get to that
place where I realized
it was one of my weaknesses.
- Have you ever tried to get
someone back that you fired?
- No.
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Because I desperately don't wanna fire.
Like,
(Milana laughing)
I really, like, it's awfully
hard to get fired in Gary Land,
you really are in DNF land around either
your skillset or your personality
and how you affect everybody else.
So, no, I've never tried
to get anybody who,
in the history of my
life I've never tried to
rehire somebody I fired.
(Milana chuckling)
I've tried to get people
back that have left.
- [Milana] Right.
- But even that's been remarkably rare.
But, yeah, that was a
real struggle for me.
What about
what about
somebody who's great at their job but is
not nice to the other boys and girls?
How much of a challenge has that been
with making a decision based on
culture versus output of skill?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And where do you
sit on that currently?
- I have no tolerance for that.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So, we had someone who was
an incredibly talented
person in their job,
but was emotionally abusive.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And had to part ways with them because--
- How long did you sit on it?
And how long did you work on it?
- So, that's a great question.
The person was with the
company for just about a year.
- When did you become
aware of, like, "Uh-oh"?
- Well, when they started reporting to me.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Because they had previous bosses
they were two layers below and
those people sheltered that.
And I had heard inklings.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But I hadn't experienced it firsthand.
- And when I did, I was like,
I have no tolerance for this.
- And so did you try to reform
or was it because you had inklings,
you kinda knew it was in the air
and you were like, "Fuck it",
this is the affirmation I needed?
- This was the affirmation,
I didn't really need to sit on it.
I think I moved within 72 hours.
- What about the industry itself?
Like, how's the competitive landscape?
How is that helping artists, you know?
- Yeah.
I think it's a really exciting time.
There's so many different partners
for artists to get their
music out there, right?
We know about the major labels
but there's all these
self-serve platforms, companies,
like DistroKid and TuneCore.
- [Gary] I love Pud.
- Pud's awesome.
- [Gary] He's the best.
- I think he's a great human,
he's someone who I talk to--
- Do you guys cross over a lot?
- [Milana] We do.
- Are you competitive?
- [Milana] You know what, it's funny,
- I always wondered that.
- People assume we're really
competitive with each other,
and, I don't know--
- Because the products are competitive?
- Not really, like, they do
want them to seem similar.
- The cliche overlap?
- [Milana] Totally.
- What do you think, you would overlap
of 50% of the things?
30% 80?
- I think less and less so.
We are not, like his user base is a lot of
both hobbyists and artists.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Who are up and coming.
- Our focus is really on artists who
either have established
management teams around them
or are further in their career cycles.
- [Gary] I see.
- So there might be a
little bit of overlap
in the early days.
- Sure, and then there's
preferences, right?
- [Milana] And there's preferences.
- Some people just like
one app over the other.
- Exactly, if you wanna pay a flat fee
or a subscription and you
don't really need much support,
with an account manager,
he's an amazing service.
- [Gary] Yep.
- If you want a bit more
hands-on strategy support,
and you want to have
an ecosystem around you
and you're collaborating with established
songwriters and producers
who need to get paid
and you need help navigating
publishers, we do that.
- Are you being used
by managers and others?
Are you a B-to-B function
to a lot of the--
- [Milana] We're mostly a B-to-B function.
- Makes sense.
- Yep, so we are embedded within
a lot of the big management companies,
like Red Light, Maverick,
Rock Nation, Full Stop, etc.
And I think that's where
we came into the market
was when I realized
there was an open spot.
There were all these
services that were serving
the longtail or DIY or the major labels
had their offerings for clients
who wanted a major label.
But if you were an up-and-coming artist
that had a manager that
represented The Migos
or Future or someone like that,
and you were up and coming
and you weren't ready for a major label,
what was the best service for them to use?
'Cause they needed to
get someone on the phone,
- [Gary] Yep.
- They wanted to have a partner
they can collaborate with
but they didn't wanna give up 30%
and so we came up with an offering
that we thought was really hitting
a sweet spot that was open in the market.
- Interesting.
Let's take it up even a higher level.
- [Milana] Yeah.
- What do you think is
interesting about music
and creators right now in general?
State of the union,
- [Milana] Yeah.
- To bring the most value
to everybody listening?
- I think that the form of music
and the purpose of music has so much more
than it ever has, right?
Let's talk about TikTok for a second.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So the purpose of music back in the day
was about education,
storytelling, saying something
and expressing yourself that other people
can't put into words which
is why you listen to songs,
you have that emotional attachment
because someone's saying
something that you can't feel,
- [Gary] Yep.
- Or you can't express.
I mean you feel it but
you can't express it.
With things like TikTok
and YouTube, right?
Music has taken a shape in which people
can make it their own
and make it the soundtrack of their lives.
And so video on YouTube
has been a place for music
to break through because
people were able to share
music video content of their own type,
not high production quality.
Like, things went viral because
of the dances people were doing,
whether it was Silento's,
I'm blanking on it, what was it called?
The song that he did?
- I'm not sure.
- The dance, oh my God.
- Don't worry.
Good news, everybody's
gonna leave comments
about what it is, keep going.
- [Milana] There we go.
- I'm sure you'll remember.
- It'll hit me in a second.
- I know about the broom challenge.
- Well that's that, right?
- [Gary] (laughing) The
less I care about today.
- Right.
- [Gary] Every day.
- There's all these songs that went viral
because people were
recording their own videos,
home videos, and posting it
with music in the background.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And with TikTok, it's like
the shorter version of that.
So we're seeing things blow up on TikTok
because people are able to use
the song's 15-second clip as like the loop
and make a video to it.
And so it's an exciting time because now,
if you're a musician you're thinking about
"How do I want people to consume my music
"and what's the best place
for me to launch it on?"
- Yeah, I understand.
- [Milana] So I think that's exciting.
- And so what about
creators
because we focused on music a little bit
but I'm interested in your take on creator
revenue splits or like how,
how strategic are the
top 5000 creators getting
with collabs and things of that nature?
- I mean, that's the best way to grow.
- [Gary] Yep.
- When you collab, right?
It's the way that you grow your audience.
- [Gary] And share.
- Into a different--
- [Gary] Audiences with each other.
- Exactly.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So I think it's
exciting and I think that
the flexibility in the deal-making
that's happening behind the scenes
is enabling things like this to occur.
The friction's starting to
go away, which is exciting.
You asked me earlier,
what's the thing I was
most surprised by to learn?
- [Gary] Yep.
- It's about, so I had
this realization this year.
We started sitting down
with a lot of artists
who started on Stem
and were getting pursued by major labels.
And the major labels were putting these
insane deals in front of them,
with huge cash up-front advances,
and the way that recruitment works
in the business is fucking crazy.
But we can talk about that separately.
And so when I would look at these deals,
I would say to the artist,
"Do you know what you're giving up?"
And they'd say, "Well,
my manager's helping me
"navigate the deal terms
"with my lawyer or business manager."
And I'd say, "Okay, has anyone
built you a financial model?
"You know how much money
you're making right now,
"because you're self-distributing.
"How much money are you
gonna give up over time
"to pay this back?
"And by the way, are you
ever gonna pay it back?
"Will you see another dollar
after this big advance?"
And what blew me away
is that when an artist
is negotiating terms
between two different offers
or looking at any offer,
no one writes them a financial model.
Like, no one does.
Whether it's an up-and-coming artist
or someone who's huge, that's established,
that's renegotiating their deals,
could you imagine taking an investment
for your business without
seeing a proforma?
- [Gary] Of course not.
- Like, how do you know
what you're gonna do
without knowing how much you're giving up?
- So when you're showing them that like,
"Cool, you're getting this check,
"but FYI do you realize that you would've
"actually made this money in 27 months
"and then own your own shit
"and then keep making
money versus never again?"
It becomes a very different conversation.
- Yeah, it completely does.
And I think people don't understand
what these deal terms mean, right?
The most artist-friendly deal
is considered a 50-50 net profit.
It's like a JV, right?
Like, I'm putting up the money,
you and I are gonna be partners,
we're gonna share the profits, right?
Sounds amazing.
- Yeah, except back in the day,
there was actually risk for these labels
because you really didn't know.
Now, they're not signing people
until the market's been
established for them anyway.
It's super-easy for them to
hedge against the downside.
- Completely.
And they're underwriting their risk
the same way for someone who's
proven a bit of traction--
- 'Course.
- To someone that's completely
- Maybe, amend the stal, these
are obvious before they sign.
- Right.
And they have historical
revenue that you can look at
to underwrite and they just don't.
It's a bidding war.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And so we announced earlier this year
a program called the Stem Check,
just because I was so frustrated
that I saw people taking deals
that they didn't understand.
And the purpose of the Stem
Check is it's open office hours,
come sit with my finance team.
I hired amazing people
from companies like SpaceX
and Yahoo Finance and other firms
that are really well
established with strong teams.
Come bring your deal terms.
They'll look at them.
Or even just tell them
hypothetical deal terms,
we'll look at your revenue,
we'll build you a model so you can
at least see what it means
to give up 50%, 30%, 70%.
And how does it look like
when you're recouping against
the gross not your share.
- Are the labels starting to understand
that they need to provide
more value than distribution
or still not yet?
- Oh yeah.
I think they're realizing that, you know,
they need to bring
these services in-house.
I think one of the biggest
changes was Napster.
And people talk about it
because it created new platforms
but what people forget
is that when Napster
blew up the music business,
people dropped all of
their shared services.
So the freelance people
who did radio and marketing
that were once employed
by the major labels
are no longer employed.
- You know what's funny about Napster?
I was more of a ShareBear user.
(Phil laughing)
Do you remember ShareBear, Phil?
I still, like ShareBear was my Napster.
That was a shout-out to
all the '90s tech kids.
Keep going.
- Yes, so all these radio promo people
that you think are only hireable
because they're employees
of the record label
are actually freelancers.
So if you have money,
you can hire them, too.
So at this point, I think
major labels for the most part
are big banks.
- Of course they are.
- They're really expensive, right?
- [Gary] Of course they are.
- They do distribution
but you don't need a label
for distribution any more.
- No, there's something
called "the internet."
- Yeah.
But what you do still need and
I think this is really rare,
is an A&R, like that person who
has a vision for you, right?
Like bringing it back to
the Jimmy Iovine days.
- So more Vince McMahon, right?
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Someone who sees you
and knows how to package
and merchandise you in
an authentic way to you,
instead of making you
do something you're not.
And take it from there.
- Yeah, because that's a
real partnership, right?
- [Gary] Right.
- And that's real talent development.
But they can't do that
when they're signing
thousands of artists a year.
So, knowing that, when
we look at our business--
- So, if you're talking to
your hypothetical sister,
who happens to be the next Billie Eilish.
- [Milana] Sure.
- And she's coming up,
what do you say to her?
How do you see it?
If she's like, "Hey,
Milana, what should I do?"
Give me the blueprint.
What is your personal opinion.
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Obviously you've built a company around
parts of it but there's
a little bit more to that
which is why I'm asking
what do you tell her?
- Depends on what you
think you're capable of
and what you need, right?
What are the jobs that you need done?
- Well, fair enough.
But I think what's most interesting
is that everybody at that
stage reverse-engineers from
"I wanna be the biggest
star in the world."
- Yeah, but you can get to being
the biggest star in the world
if you have the right
team around you, right?
But there's some people who don't know
how to put that team together.
- [Gary] Most.
- Who don't want to manage that team.
- And so that's okay,
go to a place that'll do it for you.
But if you're someone
like a Chance the Rapper
or a Frank Ocean or
someone who has the ability
to have a team around them,
and all you need is just tools and money,
there's great options for you
to go get that on your own.
- And how do you think that's playing out
for non-musicians, aka creators on TikTok
and YouTube and other
platforms that will emerge?
- There's a difference, right?
Like, we saw MCNs which
were the equivalent
of record labels and they all fell apart.
- Well, they were all over-leveraged
and got over-valued.
- [Milana] Right.
But they weren't really sustainable.
- No, but I think the question becomes,
it's like direct-to-consumer
brands, right?
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Most fail, most things
fail when they're over-valued
so extreme and people are
taking cash off the table.
That's just financial arbitrage.
- [Milana] Sure.
- Right?
And then you have founders,
and a lot of those MCNs
had that scenario where,
once you make that big payday,
the energy of building it
goes to a different place
because now you wanna buy a boat
or a nice house in the hills
instead of actually building
something meaningful forever.
To your point, the theory of it, MCN,
or theory of a manager
or an agent or a platform
can play out if it
continues to bring value
to the end user.
- It can, you're right,
but, I've even seen it.
- Do you see a lot of these people
just becoming insular
businesses themselves?
Aka, two to three
meaningful tools around them
and then six or seven
meaningful humans around them
and then that's the game?
- Yeah, I mean, that's where you see
a lot of the big management companies were
built off the back of a big artist.
Red Light was built off the
back of Dave Mathews Band.
Rock Nation was built
on the back of Jay-Z.
So you start building a team
around an artist in-house,
and then you start signing more artists
because you now have a team
- [Gary] The leverage.
- That can scale.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So, absolutely.
And I think that the new,
all the services that a
record label used to provide,
a lot of that work is happening
inside of a management company now.
- I think that's right.
So what didn't we, now
as we're wrapping up,
like what--
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Like what else do you wanna talk about?
- So the thing we're gonna announce soon
and that I'm excited about is that
we just partnered with
a firm called CoVenture.
- [Gary] CoVenture.
- And we raised $100 million
to invest in artists.
- Explain.
- So, I think that we talked about
how predatory the nature
of many advances are.
And we wanna be able to
not only educate artists
about what they're giving up
but also offer an alternative.
- Right, so, because the deals are bad,
you can go in between "bad" and "zero"
and make them what you deem as the best
alternative to the reality
of the marketplace.
- Yeah, more fairly-priced capital.
And what I think is--
- The end.
- Well, yeah.
- [Gary] It makes sense.
- But it's meant to be more
than just fairly priced.
How do you know it's fair, right?
Well, you have to know how
much are you taking out?
How much do you have to pay back?
And how long is it gonna take you?
- In essence, historically, like the best
moneylenders of all time
built the biggest companies
in the world which is how
do you get more aligned
with the person that's taking the money?
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Why did banks do a better
job than loan sharks?
It was better for the
person taking the money.
- And not only can you get the money,
but you can also get
the resources with us.
- Understood, smart money.
- Smart money.
Money that scales.
And we're calling it "Scale."
- And so, what, this
is your play into like,
is this a payback model where
you're in the financial,
or are you trying to actually have
a 3% of the back-end of Eminem?
- No, I don't want any back-end.
If you're making 10 grand a
month off your music on Stem,
- [Gary] Yep, yep.
- Your share, by the way.
You can take around $100,000 let's say,
and you can decide do you wanna pay it off
with 100% of your revenue every month?
Or do you need 5K in your
pocket to pay your rent
and other expenses.
- And you're making a
fee against the money.
- Well, you're contributing
whatever you want.
Depending on how much you wanna contribute
will determine how
quickly you pay it down.
So the faster you pay it
down, the smaller the fee.
- [Gary] I understand.
- And so you as the artist
are the person taking it out--
- And for you from a business standpoint,
because you have the math of
what they're doing on Stem,
you guys have a clean dataset which allows
you to give away money at low risk
and the lower the risk is,
the lower the percentage you charge them
based on how fast they pay back.
And so you're just, it makes sense.
- And we're in the collection flow, right?
The money comes through us--
- You're in the credit card business.
- I don't know if it's a
credit card business but--
- Well, you know, with a lot of data,
you'll have a really
good sense of how risky
the advances you're giving are
and you make small
percentages in the scheme
- [Milana] Yeah.
- Versus the big percentages
that the labels are doing.
- Yeah, and I actually believe
- [Gary] Or are there alternate things?
- That an artist doesn't have to take
that big check up front,
they should be taking,
and we're incentivizing
them with the model
to take the money they need right now,
because it's a line of credit,
they can take more over time.
- And the labels and others
will still be in business
because some people are impatient
and the thought of a $2 million check
still excites them even
though it's a bad deal.
- And the alignment with a big brand,
like a Universal,
- [Gary] Right.
- Or an Interscope or an
Atlantic is still attractive.
- Or telling your homies back at home,
like, "I signed this deal."
- [Milana] Yeah.
- So it's brand and maybe
the glitz of a bigger deal
which is less practical than something
that's a little bit more
financially responsible.
- Yeah, and listen,
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- There's always gonna be people
who make those decisions, right?
- Yeah.
There's somebody right now
who just borrowed money
paying 40% interest to
some very shady person
that's gonna break their neck
if they don't pay it back in 100 days.
That's real life, that happens.
- [Milana] Totally does,
but at least we wanna have--
- Phil's done that a couple of times.
- [Milana] Oh, God, Phil,
please don't tell me.
- But he's still here.
He always pulls it out in the end.
(laughing)
- But I think that for a
person to start thinking about
their business in terms of
how much money am I taking
and what does it mean
that I have to pay back?
Is a concept that people in music
just haven't thought about it that way.
- [Gary] I get it.
- They think about, hey, there's no fee,
it's a rev-share.
- [Gary] No, I get it.
- And that's crazy to me.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- So we're excited about that.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] It's good to see you.
- You, too.
- Where can people check out the platform?
- "Stem.is".
- I-S?
Is that Israel?
- Something like that.
- [Gary] What's I-S?
- Iceland, maybe?
Dot-com's still not available.
- I like that we didn't
know anything in this,
we didn't know the song, we don't know the
(laughing)
Isn't I?
- [Phil] Common sense.
- Is I-S Israel?
- [Phil] I don't think so.
- I don't think so, either.
- It's not Israel, Israel's I-L, I think.
- [Gary] I think you're right.
- This is--
- So it's Stem is.
- [Milana] Stem is.
- You thought about it.
- No, it was actually--
- 'Cause stem.com was
too fucking expensive?
- It's still being used,
I still can't get it.
- Fuckers.
- [Milana] I know.
- All right.
- One day.
- Good show.
One day.
- [Milana] I'm monitoring.
- After this new launch
does extremely well.
- Hopefully, right.
- Love it, good to see you.
- Thank you.
- Take care.